neuer vorsitzender für die cdu armin
laschet gewinnt das kandidatenrennen und
führt die partei jetzt in die
bundestagswahl
wie hart wird der stadt daun noch
politiker und virologen diskutieren die
deutschland durch den corona winter
kommt treffsicher in oberhof die
deutschen biathletinnen gewinnen ihr
erstes staffel rennen seit fast zwei
jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten auch heute mit
norbert lehmann für den samstag
sportschuhe
es war eine premiere heute die cdu hat
ihren neuen vorsitzenden erstmals
digital gewählt beworben hatten sich
drei juristen aus nordrhein westfalen
gewonnen hat schließlich
ministerpräsident armin laschet er wird
also nachfolger der glücklosen annegret
kramp karrenbauer in der ersten
wahlrunde landete laschet noch hauchdünn
hinter friedrich merz auf platz zwei
norbert röttgen schied aus weit
abgeschlagen
die entscheidung dann in der stichwahl
dort war das ergebnis deutlich 521 zu
466 55 stimmen machten also am ende den
unterschied und laschet zum künftigen
cdu-chef mathis feldhoff berichtet als
das ergebnis kommt entspannten sich die
gesichtszüge des siegers armin laschet
ist der neue cdu vorsitzende friedrich
merz kassiert zum zweiten mal
hintereinander eine niederlage die knapp
53 prozent für laschet müssen noch durch
eine briefwahl bestätigt werden
in einer sehr persönlichen rede wirkt
laschet um die delegierten auch in dem
er das wort vertrauen in den mittelpunkt
stellt auf dass es jetzt ankomme
dieses vertrauen muss man sich
erarbeiten und dafür reichen nicht
markige worte und schöne worte
eine spitze gegenüber seinen
konkurrenten ohne sie namentlich zu
nennen
dann höre ich immer wieder den satz man
muss auch polarisieren können
und ich sage nein muss man nicht
polarisieren ist einfach das kann jeder
die rezepte sind bekannt das gift
schnell in der hand digital schnell zu
verbreiten
laschet der jetzt 60 wird saß schon vor
26 jahren im bundestag seine karriere
ein auf und ab vor elf jahren verliert
er das duell gegen norbert röttgen um
den cdu landesvorsitz in nrw laschet war
landesminister fraktionsvorsitzender
seit dreieinhalb jahren dann auch
ministerpräsident die cdu verfolgt den
parteitag im home-office delegierte
schauen allein oder treffen sich in
kleiner runde röttgen verbündete
enttäuschte märz unterstützer und
begeisterte laschet fans ich bin
natürlich sehr glücklich dass aminas hat
der neue vorsitzende ist war im vorfeld
mein favorit und freue mich auch dass er
so eine große unterstützung und in den
delegierten bekommen hat natürlich ist
man enttäuscht es ist wie nach dem
fussballspiel ich habe einen anderen
kandidaten unterstützt aber umso
wichtiger ist es jetzt dass wir
zusammenbleiben ich denke dass die mitte
gewonnen hat jetzt geht es darum dass
armin laschet kanzlerkandidat wird und
dass die union die wahlen im september
überzeugend gewinnt auch der csu-chef
gratuliert freundlich das thema
kanzlerkandidatur spielt er bewusst
herunter armin laschet nicht werden da
bin ich ganz sicher für alle weiteren
fragen die man stehen eine gemeinsame
kluge und geschlossene lösung finden
aufregung verursacht friedrich merz als
er sich als neuer wirtschaftsminister
andient für ein parteiamt will er nicht
kandidieren in seiner rede ist er noch
ganz anders zu verstehen
ich bin mit 16 jahren in die cdu
eingetreten
ich bin nicht in eine
vermittlungsagentur für regierungsämter
eingetreten
nicht nur die kanzlerin lehnt umgehend
ab auch der neue vorsitzende weist märz
in die schranken
die führung der partei das war mein
angebot und alles andere stand in den
mittags minuten heute nicht an
norbert röttgen verhält sich anders er
versichert laschet seine loyalität
du kannst dich armin auf meine
unterstützung voll verlassen
die partei kann sich darauf verlassen
ich stehe zu meinem wort
eine haltung die sich auszahlt röttgen
wird mit einem guten ergebnis
parteipräsidium gewählt der
aufgezeichnete applaus der delegierten
gilt dem neuen vorsitzenden armin
laschet und anna banerjee das hat ja
heute viele verwundert dass sich merz
direkt als wirtschaftsminister ins spiel
bringt und zwar noch vor der
bundestagswahl und sofort die zweite
abfuhr kassiert was hatte er deinem sinn
ja das fragt sich der rest der partei
jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade auch denn
die große hoffnung die mit dieser
vorsitzendenwahl verbunden war das war
die dass die partei danach die reihen
schließt und daneben auch gemeinsam und
geschlossen in den bundestagswahlkampf
startet diese hoffnung hat friedrich
merz mit seinem verhalten heute
mindestens ins wanken gebracht
und das ist fast so etwas wie ein déjà
vu weil wir hatten 2018 bei der wahl von
annegret kramp karrenbauer ein relativ
knappes ergebnis jetzt haben wir wieder
ein sehr knappes ergebnis einen knappen
vorsprung von armin laschet und die
frage wird eben sein ist die
personalfrage jetzt nur an der
oberfläche geklärt und brodelt es im
untergrund weiter wie schnell wird es
armin laschet gelingen die beiden lager
da zusammenzuführen da bräuchte es
eigentlich auch friedrich merz dazu um
aufeinander zuzugehen heute sei es erst
mal nicht danach aus nun ist ja noch
parteichefin kramp karrenbauer auch am
umgang mit der afg gescheitert für die
es in ostdeutschland aber auch in der
cdu sympathien gibt was muss armin
laschet anders machen
das ist eine der großen fragen die er
sehr schnell wird klären müssen denn es
stehen auch wahlen an im juni in sachsen
anhalt da sind die mehrheitsverhältnisse
auch momentan nach umfragen so dass es
eine ähnlich schwierige situation geben
könnte wie in thüringen und darauf muss
armin laschet vorbereitet sein er sagt
wenn der afg wolle er sich weiterhin
ganz klar abgrenzen mit der cdu wenn da
wenn er dabei bleibt dann muss er der
ihr half die eigentlich stimmen abjagen
was anderes bleibt ihm ja nicht übrig
wie er da mit dem profil mit dem er sich
heute vorgestellt hat dazu beitragen
will das ist nicht ganz klar denn der
osten hatte doch sehr stark auch auf
friedrich merz gesetzte eben ein ganz
anderes profil gezeigt hatte steht mit
blanche c quasi fest dass er auch als
kanzlerkandidat kann kandidat ja als
kanzler kandidieren wird
nein die frage
heute weiter offen das hat er ganz klar
gesagt er möchte mit markus söder im
april darüber sprechen und dann
entscheiden und wir können davon
ausgehen dass die beiden dann auch einen
blick auf die umfragewerte werfen werden
und die frage wer kann für die cdu im
bundestagswahl beziehungsweise für die
union im bundestagswahl die meisten
stimmen holen also diese frage wird
heute noch nicht geklärt vielen dank
unter der ben ali nach berlin
und wie reagieren die anderen parteien
auf die wahl laschets schließlich ist in
acht monaten bundestagswahl unter köln
neue regierungsbündnisse geschmiedet
werden
mit einem eher liberalen cdu mann an der
spitze eröffnen sich da naturgemäß
andere möglichkeiten als mit einem
dezidiert konservativen heike slansky
hat die kommentare der anderen
eingefangen glückwünsche von den
liberalen mit laschet an der spitze wird
die fdp morgenluft sie stünde für ein
potenzielles bündnis im bund bereit es
gibt eine chance auf eine neu gegründete
zusammenarbeit zwischen union und fdp in
welcher form auch immer in der ära nach
der kanzlerschaft angela merkels ein
knappes ergebnis betont die linke und
sieht eine tief gespaltene cdu er wird
in den kommenden monaten dem rechten cdu
flügels so viel zucker geben müssen dass
sich die grünen noch gut überlegen
werden müssen ob sie sich diese union
wirklich auf gedeih und verderb
ausliefern wollen schwarz grün oder
vielleicht sogar grün schwarz kein
selbstläufer beides er mit laschet
möglich so die grünen trotzdem zweifel
auch am cdu motto werden morgen schauen
sie ihn nicht zu wenn armin laschet über
klimaschutz redet dann klingt eher nach
gegen morgen und nicht nach wegen morgen
er ist verhaftet in die alte kohle idee
der cdu
die afg findet mit laschet passe sich
die cdu an den links grünen zeitgeist an
das ist die fortsetzung von angela
merkel jetzt mit männlichen mitteln
da gibt es keine änderungen in der cdu
olaf scholz der kanzlerkandidat der spd
wünscht höflich glück auf die
parteivorsitzende dagegen eher
schmallippig die cdu ist derzeit unser
partner in der regierung und deswegen
ist es auch so wichtig dass dort die
führungsfrage geklärt ist die frage die
sie stellen nach künftigen koalition
stellt sich derzeit nicht
wer mit wem die entscheidende frage im
superwahljahr die reaktionen darauf
gemischt der neu gewählte cdu chef
stellt sich im zdf den fragen von
bettina schausten und meter frei was nun
herr laschet direkt im anschluss an
diese sendung und in der zdf- heute- app
erfahren sehen noch mehr über armin
laschet der künftige cdu chef im porträt
zum zweiten großen thema der korona lage
in deutschland und den aktuellen zahlen
laut robert-koch-institut meldeten die
gesundheitsämter 18 1678 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages gut
6000 weniger als am samstag vor einer
woche
außerdem wurden 980 neue todesfälle
registriert nach feiertagen und
jahreswechsel sollen die zahlen ab
kommender woche wieder belastbar sein
insgesamt macht die infektions lage bund
und ländern immer noch große sorgen
deshalb soll ja schon am kommenden
dienstag nachgesteuert werden
was ist da hilfreich was vertretbar
die diskussion darüber ist in vollem
gange anselm stern berichtet überall ist
sie mit dabei
die virus krise es wird erinnert an die
korona regeln etwa im harz in
niedersachsen
traumhaft viel neuschnee doch der ganz
große andrang bleibt hier aus
deutschland schenkt sich ein und steht
trotzdem wohl vor neuen schärferen
maßnahmen schon am dienstag beraten
darüber wodurch länder
ich bin der auffassung lieber jetzt kurz
und hart als dass wir eine ganz ganz
ganz lange geschichte von corona bis in
den sommer hinein haben das schadet im
übrigen auch der wirtschaft mehr als
wenn es kurz ist und das schadet auch
den schülerinnen und schüler mehr corona
neuinfektionen corona tote die zahlen
sind hoch noch immer die virus mutation
aus großbritannien macht neue sorgen vor
allem denen die entscheiden müssen die
jetzt nachdenken über verschärfungen
etwa bei den themen ausgangssperre
arbeitsplatz und masken pflicht härtere
regeln unausweichlich sagt heute der
präsident des deutschen städtetags
ich halte es für zwingend dass wir was
tun ich will und kann mich nicht
gewöhnen diese vielen toten
und insofern wir müssen runter mit den
zahlen endlich runter mit den zahlen ja
ich halte es für zwingend und viele
viele kolleginnen und kollegen in
deutschland sehen das genauso wie ich
endlich runter mit den zahlen ein ziel
das schon so lange nicht erreicht wird
die bisherigen lockdown maßnahmen sind
letztendlich nicht konsequent genug
gewesen um die kontakte zu reduzieren
wir haben uns den luxus erlaubt zu
weihnachten noch mal fakt die maßnahmen
zu lockern und die inzidenz bei den 15
bis 39 liegen dass sie überproportional
steigt ist möglicherweise auch ein
abbild das zu silvester noch mehr
gefeiert worden ist als man es
eigentlich gewünscht haben der wunsch
nach dem ende der virus zeit ist groß
auch deshalb werden die rufe lauter
nach einer harten maßnahmen verschärfung
jetzt im antik oder kampf was immer
beschlossen wird am dienstag noch eine
ganze weile wird die krise mit dabei
sein
überall zwei interessante corona
neuigkeiten noch aus deutschland über
eine million menschen sind hierzulande
inzwischen geimpft und ab jetzt dürfte
organisatorisch so einiges einfacher
werden denn laut hersteller bei montech
kann das impfserum nun auch schon als
fertige dosis in der spritze
transportiert werden
so hält es bis zu sechs stunden bei 2
bis 8 grad
mobiles impfen bei pflegebedürftigen zu
hause wäre damit kein problem mehr
verglichen mit uns hat das im programm
in indien eine ganz
unter dimensionen dort startet heute die
nach eigenen angaben größte impfaktion
der welt 1,3 milliarden menschen leben
in indien 10,5 millionen corona
infektionen wurden bisher festgestellt
über 150000 davon verliefen tödlich
jetzt sollen in einer ersten stufe bis
juli unter anderem beschäftigte im
gesundheitsbereich bei polizei und
militär geimpft werden normen odenthal
berichtet der regierungschef spricht
live und wählt gewichtige worte indien
schreibe heute geschichte jetzt zeige
das land wozu es in der lage ist dann
muss er nur noch aufs knöpfchen drücken
und die wohl größte impfkampagne der
welt gestartet
indien sagt den corona virus den kampf
an 300 tausend nadelstiche allein an
diesem ersten tag doktor sanchez ball
bekommt einen davon
wir haben alle so lange darauf gewartet
ihr mediziner pflegepersonal kämpfen an
vorderster front gegen dieses virus für
mich fühlt sich das heute wie ein
wendepunkt an ein meilenstein für uns an
zwei impfstoffe sind zugelassen
der britisch-schwedische astrazeneca und
dazu einer aus heimischen laboren der
jedoch ist umstritten weil nicht voll
durch getestet aber die zeit drängt die
produktion brummt indien ist ein gigant
auf dem pharmamarkt doch der export muss
warten indien zuerst dass die devise
zehn millionen fälle offiziell die
dunkelziffer wird viel höher sein was
manchen sogar als gute nachricht gilt
wir sind hoffnungsvoll dass wir auf dem
weg zur herdenimmunität sind denn durch
die hohen infektionszahlen haben wir
bereits ein hohes maß an durchseuchung
und immunität erreicht dazu kommt jetzt
der im perfekt jede impfstoff lieferung
ist ein fest denn das marode
gesundheitssystem die wackelige
infrastruktur die schiere dimension nach
dem startschuss heute ist indiens
impfkampagne kein selbstläufer
noch einmal nach berlin dort hat ein
bündnis von bauern und umweltschützer
innen aus rund 60 organisationen gegen
die agrarpolitik der bundesregierung
protestiert die demonstranten und
demonstrantinnen fordern eine
grundsätzliche wende in der
landwirtschaft und zwar konkret mehr
kleinbäuerliche betriebe und weniger
gross stelle für die massentierhaltung
außerdem ein verbot von pestiziden und
gentechnik anja klingbeil landwirt
jochen fritz hat einen kleinen
familienbetrieb erhält seine wasser
bevor das ganze jahr draußen
hier bekommen sie nicht nur futter und
heu von der weide sondern pflegen auch
gleichzeitig die feuchtwiesen die sonst
verstecken würden ja machen das
eigentlich weil wir auf der einen seite
die landschaftspflege machen möchten mit
den tieren und auf der anderen seite die
menschen mit hochwertigen gesunden
lebensmittel aus einer artgerechten
tierhaltung versorgen wird nachhaltige
landwirtschaft die so findet nicht nur
jochen fritz zu wenig unterstützt wird
heute protestierte er mit einem bündnis
von konventionell und ökologisch
wirtschaftenden bauern klima und
tierschützern für eine wende in der
agrarpolitik und den erhalt bäuerlicher
betriebe in deutschland
ein kritikpunkt die verteilung der
eu-subventionen moment wird geld auf
fläche verteilt also wer viel land
besitzt bekommt viel geld wir fordern
eine umverteilung hin zu einer
zielorientierten förderung von
umweltschutzmaßnahmen klimaschutz zum
tierwohl 10.000 menschen aus ganz
deutschland unterstützen die forderungen
mit ihrem fußabdruck so demonstrieren
sie pandemie konform für regional
betriebe und gegen großkonzerne
[Musik]
die demonstranten appellieren auch an
handel und verbraucher nur mit fairen
preisen könne die landwirtschaft endlich
umgebaut werden
und nun zum sport und zum erfolg der
deutschen biathleten die haben knapp
vier wochen vor der wm wieder in die
erfolgsspur gefunden
die dsv frauen gewinn souverän den
weltcup in oberhof ihr erster
staffelsieg seit knapp zwei jahren
jubel beim deutschen quartett heinz
hättig herrmann preis beim wechsel von
denise herrmann auf schlussläuferin
franziska preuß liegt belarus noch knapp
drei sekunden vorne
am letzten schießstand der showdown
franziska preuß nerven stark fehlerfrei
und schnell nach 4 x 6 kilometern ist es
vollbracht mit 17 4 sekunden vorsprung
überquert die deutsche die ziellinie vor
belarus schweden auf platz drei und es
gab noch einige andere deutsche erfolge
heute im wintersport etwa in der
nordischen kombination in val di fiemme
im team sprint siegte das duo eric
frenzel und fabian rießle vor österreich
und finnland führte im ersten team
sprint der saison wurde das zweite
deutsche duo johannes rydzek und julian
schmid und im zweierbob weltcup in st
moritz gab es sogar einen deutschen
doppelerfolg
francesco friedrich mit anschieber
alexander schüler wieder mal oben auf
das ist bereits der neunte saisonsieg
friedrichs im zehnten rennen fast eine
halbe sekunde der vorsprung auf die
zweitplatzierte johannes lockt nacht mit
anschieber florian war und auch eine
klasse für sich rekord weltmeister felix
loch er siegte beim rodel-weltcup in
oberhof
der 31 jährige thüringer feiert den
siebten einzel rennen dieses winters
winter seinen siebten sieg vor den
österreichern johannes müller und david
gleich
lochs erster sieg im gesamt-weltcup seit
2008 ist nur noch theoretisch zu
verhindern
vor dem morgigen zweiten wm-spiel der
deutschen handballer sind beim gegner
kap verde zwei neue carola fälle
entdeckt worden
die afrikaner können nun nur noch mit
neun spielern antreten vorgeschrieben
sind aber 10
die begegnung steht deshalb vor der
absage das spiel würde dann mit 10 zu 0
für deutschland gewertet werden
und hier noch die bisherigen ergebnisse
des 16 spieltags in der
fußball-bundesliga dortmund und mainz
trennten sich 1 1 hoffenheim bielefeld 0
0 wolfsburg leipzig 22
und das vierte unentschieden köln härter
null zu null bremen dagegen mit einem 2
0 sieg über augsburg das abendspiel
stuttgart gegen gladbach bereits gestern
besiegte union berlin leverkusen mit 1 0
die tabelle bayern münchen ist und
bleibt an diesem spieltag spitzenreiter
vor leipzig leverkusen und dortmund auf
den champions league plätzen
union berlin fünfter dahinter wolfsburg
und gladbach die zweite tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit stuttgart und am ende köln
mainz und schalke haben vorerst die
plätze getauscht
ja und das spiel stuttgart gegen
gladbach bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio 23 5 neuer schnee kommt in
den nächsten stunden aus westen mehr
dazu gleich von özden terli so viel von
uns schön dass sie dabei waren
das heute journal mit christian sievers
um viertel vor elf und die jetzt sofort
geht es hier weiter mit einem was nun
herr laschet einen schönen samstagabend
wünschen wir bis morgen an dieser stelle
tschüss
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der schwimmwesten
der dehnt sich allmählich weiter bis zur
mitte aus oder auch im süden und an den
alpen wird es in der nacht weiter
schneien
dabei kann es ziemlich glatt werden
durch schneeglätte ebene im osten fallen
einige schneeflocken dazwischen gibt es
häufig trockene abschnitte temperaturen
sinkt dabei auf minus 12 grad im
vogtland im westen auf minus 1 grad hier
ist es am wenigsten kalt morgen
tagesverlauf wird der schnee allmählich
im westen in regen übergehen im süden
und vor allem über den bergen also in
den mittelgebirgen und an den alpen
schneit es weiter lässt allmählich nach
ganz im osten scheint die sonne bei
höchsten temperaturen von bis zu minus
fünf grad im südosten hier dauerfrost
auch nach osten dauerfrost und 6 grad im
westen deutschlands
die kommenden tage schnee am montag im
süden bei minus 1 bis 6 grad oder am
dienstag wird es vor allem stürmisch und
mittwoch waren bis 13 grad ein schöner
abend